all right but mother's day speaking of
shopping is coming up on may 9th and if
you're still looking for something
special for mom
lifestyle expert amy sewell is sharing
some gift ideas take a look
i'm amy sewell if you're looking for
something a little different for
mother's day this year i worked with
several companies to put together some
ideas
you know how you're always flipping your
pillow over at night trying to find a
cool spot
well these silk pillowcases from
fisher's finery are a great solution for
that
because silk has been proven to help
regulate sleep temperature
moms who tend to wake up hot in the
middle of the night trying to get
comfortable
will love these now not only does silk
keep you cool and comfy at night but it
helps you look your best
during the day so many of us wake up
with bed head or
a crease across our face because cotton
pillowcases tug at your hair and skin
but since the silk fabric is so smooth
and gentle it helps eliminate
both of those problems now these were
made with the highest quality
100 pure mulberry silk good housekeeping
tested fishers finally pillowcases
and found that they outperformed
competitors that are twice as expensive
there's still time to get these in time
for mother's day at fishersfinery.com
and when you use the code shopmom1010
at checkout you save 10 on your order
moms will also love these beautiful
candles from joanna buchanan
the scents are inspired by her travels
all over the world
such as this bright net with sandalwood
what also makes these stand out is the
gorgeous packaging
as you can see each candle includes a
lid with their signature
sparkle bee the candles are then
packaged in these gorgeous boxes
with prints that were hand painted by
the designer these candles are 88
and you can find these gifts and more at
joannabuchanan.com
finally gourmet ice cream from e
creamery is a sweet way to show mom
just how much you love her their hands
turned ice creams come in traditional
flavors
but they also use candies nuts and other
bakery treats
to create delicious original varieties
their mom's sweet treat collection
includes four pints of these flavors for
the serious chocolate lovers
mom's tub of hugs wins chocolate cake
ice cream
with brownie bites and fudge swirls they
also have a vanilla
toffee crunch and a strawberry ice cream
now my personal favorite of this
collection is the meant to be my mom ice
cream
which blends mint cookie crunch with
fudge squirrels
they even include a dozen of their
delicious bakery cookies
wrapped with sweet mother's day messages
now all of the creamery's ice creams are
made in small batches
and then hand packed and shipped with
dry ice
the mom sweet treat collection is 69.99
at eve creamery.com
for more information about these and
other gifts for mom go to
shopwithstyle.com
happy mother's day thank you so much amy
for more information about these gifts
you can shop online at shopwithstyle.com